North America knowledge history let's go
play Hollywood California well this is a
big night over here
it's Oscar night within an hour 1948
outstanding film achievements will
receive the Academy Award for motion
picture people it's the final heat of
the richest sweepstakes in the country a
12-month scramble for a small statue you
could hide in your overcoat pocket
however most Hollywood people would
rather get one than hold a winning
ticket in the Grand National at this
very moment before stars producers and
executives of the moving picture colony
and before millions of listeners on this
network the program is being opened by
the Academy president mr. Gene Herschel
fellow members of the Academy had
honored guests welcome to this 21st
academy award presentation a 21st
birthday instant of course much of a
landmark for an organization which was
voting on its first birthday an
organization which came into being that
it might vote
you see equate the industry like the
motion picture industry must necessarily
judge its product primarily on the basis
of monetary profit the Academy on the
other hand has devoted itself to
honoring efforts which whether or not
they were sold in financial success
well admirable pieces of work
artistically important and enriching to
the culture from which they were
developed now that have been voices in
the industry raised against the Academy
these voices always said the same thing
we don't want Academy standards
cloistered upon us we want to make
commercial pictures unhampered by
considerations of artistic excellence
well such criticism is the highest place
to our organization to bring about a
higher excellence is the reason we exist
the reason why we must go on without
this incentive to its creative talent I
just wonder if the motion picture
industry of the world would be producing
pictures with a variety the distinction
and the Crouch which you will find in
the list of nominations for which we
shall give awards tonight with that one
thought I will turn you over to our
master of ceremonies for this evening an
officer of the Academy mr. Robert
Montgomery
thank you ladies and gentlemen and good
evening I've attended many of the 20
previous award ceremonies occasionally
as a candidate but a great deal more
often as a spectator I've observed the
modesty with which the winners have
received their awards I've heard the
stumbling words of gratitude that they
have poured out for their producers
their directors their fellow workers
I've always wanted to win one of those
Oscars because it would have given me a
chance to say something like this fellow
members of the Academy and accepting
this award I want to thank you and
nobody else
I want it thoroughly understood that I
wanted to spite in obstreperous front
office and unsympathetic producer an
incompetent direct and inadequate cast a
very poor script indeed an uncooperative
crew and a skinflint of a banker I did
it all by myself
I suppose I wouldn't have been that
ungracious nor that untrue but it would
have been a very great temptation human
eardrums can stand just so much modesty
in self-effacement and so tonight the
committee instructs the winners of all
Awards whoever they may be that is their
own achievement which is being rewarded
we take it for granted that nobody did
his or her job single-handed but if you
want to acknowledge your indebtedness do
it by letter or by phone
collect if necessary tonight all credit
acknowledgments are hopefully forbidden